so the title of this that hyperlink to
it is female hypocrisy
101 by whatever podcast so this is what
they're talking about which is making
women look done so we'll just check this
out women have been oppressed since the
beginning of time
are you really how yeah go ahead how
you're the one saying this is true women
were oppressed in history but so were
men
it's not it's not as much now this is
this is interesting because if I say how
were women oppressed you're like well
it's self-evidence Brian I shouldn't
have to educate you yet you've just
asked me the same question you've just
asked how we're menopressed shouldn't
you know no because that wasn't taught
in school ah so isn't that interesting
male oppression was never taught in
school female suppression was
isn't that interesting so who's really
oppressed then oh my God Ryan if if
men's grievances throughout history
are overlooked who's the real one that's
pressed
perhaps you don't even believe men are
breast
to be honest you don't yeah
woman okay so you know this is your this
is your typical uh guest of the show I
guess is essentially what they're trying
to say
uh let's pull the article back up
present sure screen
there it is now that we got that
hyperlink out of the way uh by
belittling female guests I don't know
that this guy Brian the host was
belittling this gal
um I'll get into some of the details why
that is in a moment we'll just read
through the article on what our friend
uh Brooke Cato has to say here about
this making them look dumb whatever uh
in quotations is hosted by Brian Atlas
uh it masquerades as a dating talk show
while delving into gender roles body
counts and the legitimacy of the
patriarchy the podcast team uses social
media to seek women panelists only to
later roast them
with online uh sorry roast them online
in Snippets pandering to the vir to the
virality of the inflammatory hot takes
so in other words it's perfect click
bait it absolutely is so here's uh I
guess a panel of a recent show it says
whatever podcast from slammed for
belittling women you've got destiny the
blue-haired bisexual dude that lets his
wife uh over here sleep with whoever she
wants
um the rest of the gals from the panel
this dork over here I talked about him
in a community post and I'm not sure who
this guy is and this guy is and he's
wearing a wig I guess I don't know if
he's trying to mock this guy over here
or uh what the story is but anyway he's
wearing one of his red uh toupees I
guess in one episode The panelists Who
are all women rate themselves as tens
much to atlas's shock well okay that's
certainly going to drive some
controversy I wonder if there's like a
pre-screen that they asked him like how
would you rate yourself you know before
they bring them on and they bring on
women that rate themselves as tens in
advance maybe maybe not I don't know
anyway uh I'mma Be honest I'm not going
to rate you guys but none of you guys
are a 10. he says in response uh
prompting a course of agreement in the
comments by users cruelly joking about
the women's weight and appearance
um to this point over here
the course of agreement you see in the
comments of these live shows and they
generate a lot of live views
um
it's kind of trendy now it's like the
trending thing right do a podcast sit at
a table with a bunch of people uh if you
gotcha moments there's a few
um you know Revelations from body count
from their views on feminism on the
patriarchy on the oppression of women
and that sort of stuff and of course
you've got viewers watching it who are
just
um they're just slamming the people on
the piano usually just the women
um they're making jokes about their
appearance their weight their
entitlement and look
are they entitled
yes generally speaking are they usually
bimbos yeah generally speaking like
they're not they're not putting their
best on you know if you know what I'm
saying like they're not getting
you're not seeing classy women on there
because classy wouldn't women wouldn't
wouldn't make the show work so having
low IQ entitled bimbos that aren't tuned
into the reality of the world that have
a skewed view which most women generally
do because they're solipsism they really
can't see Pastor own knows at the end of
the day but the viewers are the other
thing that I see that pops up a lot too
is you get a lot of these
I don't know if they're disgruntled if
they're upset if they're mgtows if
they're in cells or what they happen to
be but watching two three four five
eight hours I don't know how long they
run I mean they seem to run for several
hours I only ever watch the clips
um because those because those are the
ones that are shown to me by the
algorithms but I know they run for
several hours and a lot of these dudes
are sitting there in the comments and
they're sending like massive super chats
um I'm not talking like five ten bucks
with it with a general question to be
asked it's like 50 100 500 they're huge
um usually with slanderous statements to
the panelists
um so I mean you can take it what it's
for what it's worth
I've got a lot of dope friends and we do
dope [__]
um you know I'm the guy that likes doing
super car rallies and stuff like that
and business dealings and Investments
and none of the guys that I roll with
have time to be in the comments
belittling uh people via Super Chat that
gets shown up on the screen so there's
that element of it too as well which
sort of drives it fuels the fire okay if
you will I I mean
I don't see this as a long game for
creators doing this type of model so you
notice what it is but again prompting a
course of agreement in the comments by
users cruelly joking about the women's
weight and appearance uh in in another
Atlas grills the panelists on their body
counts and how many people they've been
intimate with and is met with resistance
well
of course it's going to be and women
will never be honest about their body
counts anyway at the end of the day I've
said this many times guys
um if you ask a woman what her body
count is she generally only remembers
guys that she was intimate with over a
long-term basis boyfriends guys that she
dated for several months guys that she
might have pine for that she was perhaps
Alpha widowed by they don't they have
amnesia when it comes to things like
threesomes what happened in the
nightclub bathroom what happened in
Vegas or Ibiza stays in Vegas or VISA
um all of those things they just don't
have a recollection of it so asking the
numbers is kind of pointless at the end
of the day but what it does is it drives
conversation around well how dare you
ask a woman how many guys that she's
been with because in the modern era that
we live in you know men and women have
been told that they're the same women
have been told well if men are
promiscuous then women can be
promiscuous without any consequences
but what they end up doing is they uh
seem to try to hold these women
accountable to standards and if a
chick's been with 50 guys like I've seen
videos here there was one that was a uh
a clip that got uh some viral push where
this very average looking girl probably
a four or five you might rate her like
most of the public
um was talking about being with 100 guys
plus and I think there was some
conversation if I'm not mistaken if it's
not the same girl it was another one but
she said that she had uh several of them
in a week and in some cases in the same
night so
of course that's going to get pushed
back and it's get some it's going to get
some virality in the algorithms because
what it does is it just reinforces what
guys that are struggling with women
um are experiencing which is women are
trash right and that's that's really
where it it takes us and what this
article is probably going to drive at by
the time we get to the end of it and I
don't think that all women are trash but
I also don't think that all women are
pure either right like there's like
there's something going on there in
between
it just so happens to be that the panels
that are selected for these shows look
again like I said earlier they're not
sending their best are they right anyway
uh girls of panelists body counts that's
met with resistance of course right
because women have traditionally uh not
liked being [__] shamed so you know they
they try to downplay it obviously uh in
quotations it says here it doesn't
matter to me but it matters to you guys
one woman said gesturing to the men
sitting around the table so I'm not
going to go and put myself out there and
say my body count just for you to
ridicule me or something well of course
you're going to be ridiculed if you
volunteer that you've been with a whole
bunch of dudes because you inherently
know that it's disgusting right but this
is what the show is trying to
highlight you know I suppose right he
goes on to say while only fans models
Nicolette Nicole admitted that her
appearance on the podcast was to bolster
her own following let's see who this is
I'm just clicking through on here
um I think I can share this on the
screen but just for context there's a
little bit of uh sexy time on this one
so this is who Nicolette Nicole is this
is her link that was hyperlinked in
there she looks like an only fans
Creator girl
and you know I guess if you tell them
hey you know you can link your only fans
Below in the show notes then they'll
then they'll probably be more interested
in doing it because
what woman that is doing something like
only fans doesn't want to recruit more
thirsty beta followers in her orbit so
anyway so this gal Nicolette Nicole
admitted that her appearance in the
podcast was the bolster her own
following she told Vice uh that the
clips were definitely chosen Vice
that publication sucks let me just
hyperlink this and see where it goes
latest Trend podcast making women look
dumb this is the exact same title of
this article but it's written by
Magdalene Taylor
huh so they're okay I'm gonna come back
to that in a second because maybe
there's some references in there so she
links to this other article with the
exact same title written by another
journalist
and shame her well
look if you're selling pictures of your
butthole online on an app of course
people are going to offer their opinion
on that the vast majority of the public
doesn't agree with it I think most only
fans creators that do that as a job
understand that it is detrimental to a
healthy relationship with a man I mean
maybe some lib left-leaning Progressive
sort of blue and hair dude will be okay
with it but the traditional guy that
she's going to be attracted to the
strong masculine virtuous sort of guy
that she wants is going to frown upon it
and I think inherently these creators
these only fan creators know that so I
think this article is being a little bit
disingenuous from that perspective too
anyway controversy make her look dumb
and shame her well yeah you're selling
pictures of your butthole you are going
to look dumb you know if you try to
defend that I'm not going to argue with
that some screenshots here you're a 10
question mark no tens with his hands out
Twitter and Tick Tock the videos
provocative one-line captions lure
thousands to millions of views only only
sorry only fans girls get roasted the
podcast tweeted let me just hyperlink
that and see where that takes me
I'm checking them first to make sure
um yeah you guys okay yeah so I can
share this one with you
um present your screen
so the title and they use clickbaity
titles too you know for being honest
right
like this one says only fans girl gets
roasted getting thrown out uh roasted uh
rage quitting what are the other ones
that I've seen Frank castled that's
another version of getting thrown out
um they have all these different
versions that have you know become
trendy now but so this is the hyperlink
that opened up for the only fans girl
that purportedly got roasted that I
opened up the other link to her Twitter
so let's see what this one here has to
say I'm just gonna speed it up a little
bit and volume up go so both you do only
fans how much you make Glenn make a lot
how much from
oh my God
disagreements but so we both of you do
only fans how much do you make I make a
lot again like you're not finding the
best out there you're not even finding
remotely close to even remotely average
women like you're dealing with well like
whatever that's just bad vibes right
like this is the this is the response to
the uh fair and I think just criticism
of her life choices and she just
dismisses it as it's just bad vibes well
you are going to be judged for being
promiscuous that is a reality of the
world I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out